the nfl has been insisting on two
preseason games one home one away for
every team so they can go through the
motions of the game day pandemic
protocols the players have been saying
chris no preseason games they want to
have the full opportunity of training
camp to get in game shape they don't
want guys to be prematurely in a game
setting and they see no upside from
playing these preseason games it's
opportunities for an outbreak the
revenue is not there why are we doing it
that's been the union's position i was
told last week that very likely the end
result will be one preseason game
featuring teams that are in some
geographic proximity giants jets in the
same stadium chargers rams for example
when you start looking around the league
though you're still going to have a team
that's going to have to get on an
airplane and go somewhere but the idea
is to minimize the travel and to have
that one game according to nfl media
that's officially been proposed to the
union one game in the preseason the nfl
has moved off of two the nfl moved from
four to two
beyond any negotiations and now as these
negotiations continue the nfl has moved
from two to one the union still wants
none chris so i don't know where this
ends up and i don't know how i feel
about even one preseason game i
understand the importance of
of making sure that that everything is
going to work right
in a setting where the game doesn't
count and and having everyone feel what
it's going to be like on game day with
these new procedures but you know i
understand where the players are coming
from too you want to make sure that you
are keeping your players uh ready
getting them ready keeping them healthy
and keeping them out of an unnecessary
opportunity potent to potentially be
exposed to the virus yeah i i mean look
i get it i get the i get the nfl wanting
to have the preseason game just to go
through the procedure a little bit and
do that
but to me
you know the risk isn't worth the risk
it ain't worth the biscuit here to me i
just you know again i know that's
probably how they want to do see how
they can map it out make it better
whatever it may be okay cool listen it's
not gonna be that much different than
when the teams check into their
facilities on a daily basis for training
camp or whatever it may be except you're
gonna have to have two of those uh you
know medical teams in a stadium so but
but to me the big thing is why risk it
why don't do it it's just not worth it
at this point to me as a player and even
as a fan i'm not even trying to say it
i'd love to sit there and watch
pre-season football but i don't want
pre-season football if it's going to
sacrifice me seeing regular season
football and then just this this year
with what we got you know again this is
where i'm i'm if i'm like ahead of the
nflpa right now or one of the player
reps i'm pushing back for the seas the
season to be pushed back a little bit i
really am because i think you're going
to need more time to get players ready
to play football this year than ever
before and that preseason game's not
going to make everybody ready it's not
going to be like the magic pill and like
everyone's going to get done and go oh
we're ready to go no it's so it's really
going to make not a big difference that
way
so to me the more important thing would
be let's get back into the training
facilities let's take two weeks of just
training lifting weights conditioning
running every day then another two or
three weeks of otas basically helmets
practice running around no contact then
you get into the contact aspect and now
you go okay we're to put shoulder pads
and start doing some full pad periods
and things like that which need to get
hashed out too because that's an area
where the veteran players right now
don't want to do 11 on 11 and that's not
going to help at some point we're going
to have to play 11 on 11. i would just
rather see the teams do it themselves
have scrimmages have full contact
scrimmages but let's limit the amount of
people here as long as we can to save
the bigger picture which is the season
uh for the nfl in 2020.
i'm telling you what though
i can't envision a situation where the
nfl voluntarily bumps back the start of
this i know i think that i think that
when you consider what's happening with
the pandemic the nfl is even more
determined to get to week one and see
what happens because if you start
delaying things may get worse we get
into cold and flu season i think they
want to get these games in they want to
get their procedures honed and they want
to see if they can indeed
minimize outbreaks on a given team and
there's a lot of factors there's a ton
of moving parts
and and i i don't even think the nfl at
this point is trying to convince anyone
that the approach is anything other than
let's see what happens but there is a
strong let's see what happens element to
what's happening now in the nfl and i
think one thing the nfl wants to have
happen is they want to start september
10 with that first game chiefs texans
full slate of games ah three days later
on september 13 and then the way the
schedule was constructed yeah the way it
was built
week two can be easily absorbed
later into the season because every game
from week two features two teams are out
there by the same week they can wipe out
week two and regroup week three week
four no divisional games those can be
cancelled or they can be tacked on to
the end of the schedule if they decide
to move things back but i think they're
determined to get through week one and
then reassess
see how it's working and if it works
keep going if they need some time they
have the benefit of time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports